reason to see number six writing and
directing I just remember watching the
first ten minutes of this film on going
yeah this is one of my favorite movies
of the year and then someone told you to
stop talking during it's his first movie
where everyone is not talking about
cinema why ening grossing film I mean
that the trailer shows you a badass
story about a slave essentially taking
his uprising but the film just gives you
so much more than just that it's the
perfect blend of homage and complete
originality he's very upfront about what
he pays at lunch to this man knows how
to create a revenge tale were you as the
audience want revenge yeah it's a
revenge story in a redemption story all
at the same time and then mixed with a
buddy story to this guy once again
showcases his expertise for authentic
dialogue every character in this film
has her own unique way of speaking yes
the slavery in this movie is portrayed
in such a harsh light and at the same
time you don't feel like he's trying to
shove a message in your face though the
last hour to an hour a half of this
movie is like a play and I love it
expect the unexpected but also expect
what exactly what you want out of this
he knows how to put his characters in
his situations where you wonder like how
are they gonna get out of this it gets
to the point where you feel like anyone
could die at any moment that this movie
is like two stories in one one story is
about Django and his journey to becoming
a bounty hunter the other story is about
a bounty hunter on a mission to rescue
his wife this is almost a three hour
movie but you feel ready for another
adventure right away I want to sure let
out of this in a world today will it
seems like unnecessary sequels or movies
at end on an obvious note that a sequel
is coming rare is the occasion where you
don't hear about a sequel being planned
yet you want one so damned bad yes like
I remove it it's like a sequel is it
give it nowadays and then it's always
the movie where it doesn't seem like
it's a given that you want a sequence of
it you know there's so much emotion
being generated in this film in such a
unique fashion and yet it never feels
forced reason to see number seven humor
so one more comedy than I anticipated
for this film Tarantino usually has
comedy in his lines but for this
particular film I would have to say one
of the genres is comedy there's the one
seen with with the the clan members with
the bags over their heads and stuff like
that and that scene like flat-out is a
comedy scene this is pure comedy I mean
there is a good at 40 minutes of this
film where there's not much comedy going
on but at the end of the day there's
still two thirds of this movie that has
a lot of comedy Tarantino just knew how
to accuse comedy into this film but not
take away from the serious elements
there's lots of humor and snappy
dialogue and in some of the situations
too it's not like he's just throwing
jokes out you know it's like people
reacting to situations and the humor
that comes out through that at the end
of the day even the comedy itself feels
authentic am I paying this is one of the
funniest movies of the year risen to see
number eight violence the violence is
fun it's over the top it's whimsical at
times see the thing about the violence
is that it's whimsical at the right
times and it's harsh at the right time I
mean there's this there's a lot of
moments where you you're cringing at it
you know the violence goes back and
forth you know some of it is kind of fun
and over the top and some of it is is
harsh you know and it's um you know it's
completely cringe-worthy reason to see
number nine the cinematography it's a
violent film yes but there's a certain
Beauty to the way the movie is
a lot of scenes were captured through
the master shop which I adored because
as an audience member it's like the
ultimate observation you find your head
going like this a lot just looking and
back and forth between two characters in
the scene and I might seem annoying when
I do it on camera but when you actually
watch the movie it makes it that much
more exciting because it's like you get
to choose what to look at now you can
sort of study the frame yeah yeah the
cinematography is kind of a character in
and of itself you know because you have
all these intense zooms and these whip
pans back and forth and stuff and it
really sort of communicates that old
spaghetti western idea that he's going
for we've to see number 10 the score the
music in this film ranges from your
oldies to rap to complete original music
yet each song fits perfect for each
scene for some reason hood I feel like
the song choices were already there in
Tarantino's mind before he directed or
even wrote the scenes it gave more to
the film than the average movie score
does you know like the cinematography
the music in this movie is also a
character there's obvious purpose to
each music choice he paints probably
with the music you know it always has to
do with what's going on but it's also
painting with moods more than you know
having lyrics that pertain to the
situation you know is it just feels
intuitive almost like instinctually it's
great because not even the rap music and
take you away from the feeling that
you're back in the Old West reason to
see number 11 the production design it
wasn't too flashy was really grounded in
reality it really feels like you're at
that time period I mean the house is the
costumes just everything about it looks
so authentic and so beautiful I also
really appreciated that everyone has
like disgusting teeth every character
there's a couple scenes where I think
like you know Django's got a pretty nice
setup early ennio schultz is a dentist
at some point in time so he's got okay
too but but like all these other recipes
like these rich southern plantation
owners and some of these enormous
sounds like they all happy a disgusting
black teeth the tooth design is a reason
to see the specific reasons not to see
can't really find and there aren't any
yeah this movie was perfect I can see
things that people might be offended by
I can you know it's an extreme movie
it's taryn teen they do use the n-word
like over a hundred times I got 109 110
something like that I heard the number
yeah it's pretty ridiculous yeah but for
me personally I felt it was an authentic
choice for the film I thought it made it
that much more believable and I thought
to that you know maybe people did talk
like this back then I don't know anyway
it makes sense though when you watch the
movie because I I didn't walk out of
this movie going they use the N word a
lot I it does bleed into the film it
blends perfectly Tarantino is a device
if you'll make him to begin with and
he's a filmmakers it takes a lot of
liberties and you know he's certainly on
tour so he always uses the N word anyway
just know what you're getting into
there's there's lots of extreme stuff in
it but um yeah I think of it's for you
you'll know and if you don't like it
you're a [ __ ]